so let's talk about some battleground
states for 2020 right now because we've
got to be honest very rarely are
presidential elections decided by who
wins Massachusetts or how big a margin
of victory the Democrat has in
California those things influence the
popular vote but of course we have an
electoral college system in the u.s. so
reality check time tomorrow we will talk
about how in national polls Donald Trump
is way way way down in hypothetical
matchups against Joe Biden by 17 points
against Elizabeth Warren by 16 points
against Bernie Sanders by 14 points but
do we believe that Donald Trump is going
to lose the popular vote by 15 16 or 17
points in 2020 I don't think so
it would be historic it wouldn't be
impossible but it would be historic and
we haven't seen anything like that for a
very long time so if we assume that the
popular vote nationally is going to
tighten up as we get closer and closer
to the election the most likely scenario
is that a few key battleground states
are going to decide 2020 so I think it's
a logical time less than a year out from
the election at this point to start
looking at who of the Democratic
frontrunner is doing best in those
states and right now it is not Elizabeth
Warren now of course I know that there's
constant discussions over a my a Bernie
bro a my a Warren chill or whatever I'm
not any of those things I tell you what
the facts are and what the polls say a
new New York Times poll looked at six
important states those states are
Michigan Pennsylvania Wisconsin Florida
Arizona and North Carolina in
hypothetical matchups against Donald
Trump in those states Joe Biden is
winning four states Bernie is winning
three and Elizabeth Warren is winning
only one Arizona right now according to
state polls Biden would defeat Trump in
Pennsylvania Wisconsin Florida and
Arizona but lose North Carolina and they
are tied in Michigan so that's four for
Biden Bernie right now would beat Trump
in Michigan Pennsylvania and Wisconsin
but would lose to Trump in Florida
Arizona and North Carolina and Warren is
leading Trump in Arizona losing
in Michigan Florida and North Carolina
and tied in Pennsylvania and Wisconsin
so on this basis if we say electoral
college presidential elections in the
United States typically come down to
these states Biden and Bernie are
looking far stronger than Warren but
there's actually even worse news for
Elizabeth Warren that polling was among
registered voters but as we know not
everybody who is registered actually
votes if you look at likely voters it is
a disaster for Elizabeth Warren it's
also slightly worse for Bernie but not
nearly as much worse as it is for Warren
among likely voters Biden wins five of
these key states all of them from North
Carolina all of them but North Carolina
Bernie wins just one Michigan while he's
losing to trump and four and Elizabeth
Warren among likely voters is behind in
five of the six states and even only in
one of them Arizona but let's dig deeper
this is not enough what about Ohio Ohio
has been a big marker for presidential
elections and a big battleground Ohio
was not included in this poll of key
states if we look at polling in Ohio
which is admittedly a month old at this
point
Warren is plus four over Trump in Ohio
Bernie has a bigger lead with plus six
and Biden also at plus six so all of the
normal caveats here things can change
between now and November of 2020 it's
early electability is a fraud issue
likability as part of that is an even
more fraught issue but as we get closer
and closer these are going to be real
issues to talk about now as far as it
being early it is early but in the last
three presidential elections when you
looked at polls head-to-head
hypothetical matchups a year in advance
they were essentially just as accurate
as the day before the election so while
it is early and things can change often
they don't and often hypothetical
matchups at this point can actually tell
us quite a bit quite a bit so these
numbers don't look good for Elizabeth
Warren I want to hear from you what do
you make of them but the other thing we
should really be looking at our voter
cross-sections
because Donald Trump's advantage with
white voters particularly those that are
not college-educated continues to be
something that is truly a house of
horrors and effectively a dystopian
nightmare and that's what I want to get
into next in detail